[Musik]
tatort deutschland die crime doku von
bild
es ist der 17 september 2013 wir finden
uns in essen wieder und folgen einem
geistig behinderten jungen mann auf
seinem weg in den getränkemarkt unweit
von seinem zuhause um fand geld zu
bekommen will er hier seine flaschen
abgeben doch weil diese wie so häufig
noch halb voll sind kommt es zu einer
diskussion mit der verkäuferin hilflos
verlässt er den getränkemarkt und
versucht stattdessen in einem
nahegelegenen penny neu getränke zu
kaufen doch sein geld reicht nicht aus
er versucht mit einem alten kassenzettel
zu bezahlen und wird natürlich
abgewiesen am frühen abend gegen 19 uhr
15 verletzte den supermarkt doch bis
nach hause schafft er es nie denn
seitdem fehlt jede spur von peter parker
an manchen tagen da wird man morgens
schon auf und kommt einfach nicht mehr
aus dem gedanken heraus diese
ungewissheit ist fast nicht mehr auswahl
die sorge immer noch zu glauben lebt
mein kind noch wird seit jahren gefangen
gehalten und ich glaube das ist was viel
mehr zermürbt als vielleicht eine
grausame gewissheit klages tage wo ich
nicht dran denke aber es gibt kein monat
ruhig jetzt mal gar nicht verlängern
würde wie ist es möglich dass ein junger
mann mitten in essen am hellichten tag
während des einkaufens vermutlich von
einem supermarktparkplatz verschwindet
wie kann es sein dass ich bis heute bei
der polizei kein zeuge gemeldet hat der
wirklich weiß was mit pia parke
geschehen ist
mein name ist sky dumont und ich begrüße
euch zu einer neuen ausgabe von tatort
deutschland
wer war pia parke ein 21-jähriger
blonder junger mann mit einem
ansteckenden freundlichen lächeln er
liebt autos und sucht nähe zu anderen
menschen doch viele verstehen ihn nicht
denn er war schon immer anders anders
als die anderen der kleine pierre kommt
als frühchen zur welt bei der geburt
wird sein gehirn mit zu wenig sauerstoff
versorgt was die ursache für seine
darauffolgende entwicklungsstörung ist
auch als erwachsener hatte die
fähigkeiten eines kleinkindes kann weder
rechnen noch lesen nur einen tag nach
seiner geburt stirbt seine leibliche
mutter an einem leberschaden hier wächst
beim vater und seine stiefmutter auf mit
einer besonders engen bindung zu seinen
großeltern und zu seinen älteren bruder
daniel als dieser aus dem elternhaus aus
zieht fühlt pia sich zurückgelassen aus
angst vor einsamkeit zieht der junge
mann im jahr 2012 in ein wohnheim für
menschen mit behinderungen nach nicht
einmal einem jahr dort verschwindet der
hilflose tier spurlos
der fall erschüttert große teile des
ruhrgebietes und darüber hinaus auch in
der essener bildredaktion kann man sich
noch genau an den fall erinnern
in einem konferenzraum reicht das team
bestehend aus mehreren erfahrenen
reporter zahlreiche alte titelblätter
zum thema php
pierre auf parkplatz verschwunden angst
um vermissten pierre spur führt ins
rotlichtviertel von amsterdam
allen voran chefreporter frank schneider
kümmert sich um den tragischen fall der
grossgewachsene brillenträger stand in
engem austausch mit der familie des
vermissten und hat deshalb ein
besonderes verständnis für dessen
situation hier ist es eben so dass ein
erwachsener verschwunden ist derweil das
geistige niveau eines kindes hat und
wirklich als hilflos gilt und die
familie sich deshalb auch von anfang an
große sorgen machen das war sehr schnell
klar der ist nicht freiwillig weg diese
familien hat schon soviel schicksal
erlebt so findet ihr nennt erlebt jetzt
musste ihnen das auch noch wieder fahren
das hat einen muss man sagen auch als
reporter natürlich nicht kalt gelassen
das polizeipräsidium in essen hier ist
frank schneider mit ralf horst
verabredet corona konform begrüßte
kriminalhauptkommissar den chefreporter
und führt ihn in sein büro seine klaren
blauen augen wirken mitfühlend als er
über den möglichen zustand des
vermissten aufklärt die hoffnung
tatsächlich habe ich das hier noch leben
kann das ist nicht ausgeschlossen aber
es kann im schlimmsten fall den wir auch
so sein dass pia schon vor längerer zeit
gestorben ist und hier einfach ihn nicht
finden können ich hoffe immer das war
nochmal zu einer lösung kommen das
klappt ja wir finden oder zumindest ein
ergebnis bekommen aber abschließen
können der ernsten gesichtern der junge
mann lebte zuletzt in essen will dorf in
eine einrichtung für menschen mit
behinderung die bewohner durften sich
auch außerhalb frei bewegen frank
schneider geht den weg vom wohnheim zum
getränkemarkt entlang eine der letzten
stationen von pia palme
diesen weg nur zwei mal wieder von
behinderten wohnheim in essen entfernt
in pr parker eigentlich jeden tag er
wollte hierzu den getränkemarkt auch am
tag seines verschwindens die bilder der
überwachungskamera zeigen die letzten
aufnahmen des lebenden tier ein
schmächtiger mann in jeans und
cremefarbenen pulli mit schwarzen
streifen an den ärmeln er wird etwas
hilflos durch den laden auch im
kommissariat sind die wichtigsten
ausschnitte des videos in papierform
ausgedruckt in den akten zu finden ralf
menkhaus zeigt auf eines der
schwarz-weißen leicht verschwommenen
bilder vor ihm das in bilder die zeigen
auch in seiner typischen art wie er sich
bewegt hat seine bekleidung
pierce weg führt ihn schließlich zu
einem penny bei dem er versuchte sich
neue getränke zu kaufen ohne erfolg
niedergeschlagen verließ er den
supermarkt zwischen 19 15 und 20 uhr was
danach geschah ist bis heute ein rätsel
frank schneider und ralf menkhaus stehen
sich vor dem genannten supermarkt
gegenüber während der bild-reporter kers
ausgangslage zusammen fasst diesen laden
dort durch die tür verlassen da ist die
ausfahrt richtung autobahn dann könnte
also theoretisch haben wir stehen genau
an der stelle wo er mich als auf den
täter betrunken auch der ehemalige
leiter der ermittlungen stimmt diese
annahme zu während er sich auf dem
parkplatz um sieht das könnte
tatsächlich so sein also wir sehen ihren
bereich auch
verschiedene geschäfte
auch verschiedene fahrzeuge auf diesem
parkplatz verlassen hin wieder und
hier kann alles passieren
der fall wird von der polizei essen wie
der eines kindes behandelt durch seine
behinderung war hier genauso leicht zu
beeinflussen ist er womöglich in ein
fremdes auto gestiegen ralph denk rost
ist sich sicher dass an dieser theorie
etwas dran sein könnte grundsätzlich war
begeistert von autos und hat sich auch
im heim gerne solche sachen belohnen
lassen also es war so eine eine geste
dort das was etwas gut gelaufen ist und
was gut gelaufen ist dass er dann mit
einem auto mitfahren können das fand ich
immer toll und insofern ist das
natürlich ein einfallstor gewesen für
einen täter wie die presse über den fall
erfahren hat weiß frank schneider noch
ganz genau wir haben sehr schnell davon
erfahren weil die familie so einen tag
danach schon selber super karte auf
gehangen hat mit ihren handy nummern
dadurch hatten wir sehr schnell kontakt
zur familie auch der kontakt zur polizei
ist hier bei uns sehr vertrauensvoll und
gut und deswegen haben wir auch sehr
schnell kontakt zur polizei aufgenommen
und dort war die sorge auch sofort sehr
groß es wurde umgehend gehandelt die
polizei bildete sofort eine
ermittlungskommission und schickte sucht
truppen in jedem teil der stadt
krankenhäuser öffentliche verkehrsmittel
und taxiunternehmen wurden kontaktiert
und auch das waldgebiet unweit des
besagten penny wurde mit hochdruck
durchkämmt hauptkommissar ralf menkhaus
erklärt auf welche außergewöhnlichen
methoden die polizei essen damals
zurückgegriffen hat
sämtliche suchmaßnahmen befragungen im
näheren umfeld
erfolglos beenden mussten haben wir
weiter überlegt wo er sein könnte es
gibt die möglichkeit hat mit suchhunden
jemanden auf zu finden bzw dessen spur
zu verfolgen das haben wir in diesem
fall auch mit den sogenannten mantrailer
unten gemacht und dann sind wir im
grunde ohne eine einrichtung bloß
gegangen und waren sehr überrascht
[Musik]
anfang oktober 2013 folgt nach bereits
monatelanger suche endlich ein
durchbruch
mantrailer hunde die gezielt nach
vermissten personen suchen führen die
ermittler zu einem auto und einer
wohnung ganz in der nähe von pias
wohnheim und sowohl der halter des
fahrzeugs als auch der mieter der
wohnung sind wegen sexuellen missbrauchs
vorbestraft
verbindung
und sprechen keine beweislage schaffen
so hauptkommissar ralf mein kurs zu bild
reporter frank schneider aber
ausschließen kann man es auch nicht
ganz ausschließen kann es nicht wenn da
kein geständnis kommt oder eine eigene
einlassungen über in dem fall jetzt auch
nicht halten können wir das nicht
beweisen und dann sind wir genau so
schlau wie zuvor
doch die hunde führen zu einer weiteren
heißen spur ebenfalls unweit von cayes
wohnheim die ehemalige autobahnauffahrt
von essen frillendorf
schneider und mengen kost folgen den
schildern der begrünten und mittlerweile
geschlossenen anschlussstelle richtung
dortmund dollar die spur unweit von hier
im bereich seines wohnheims und bei den
letzten aufenthaltsort in verschiedenen
getränkemärkten da haben wir in einem
letzten parkplatz einen spur dass wir
sagen da da da wissen wir nichts mehr
also ist die vermutung dass er dort ein
auto gestiegen
genau wissen wir es natürlich mich aber
letztlich müssen wir davon ausgehen dass
er mit einem auto wie auch immer ein pkw
ein lkw auf dieser autobahn gekommen ist
und eine fortbewegung zu fuß scheidet im
grunde aus
die hunde verfolgten die spur sogar noch
weiter über die a 40 richtung duisburg
und über die a 3 richtung arnheim bis
ins amsterdamer rotlicht milieu wo sich
die spur endgültig verliert bei solchen
suchen wird natürlich nicht eine ganze
autobahnstrecke über hunderte kilometer
erschnüffelt tatsächlich wird mit hilfe
der hunde jeweils an den raststätten
überprüft ob sich die spur des gesuchten
wieder findet und er folglich
umgestiegen sein könnte wegen der spur
nach holland kommt der schreckliche
verdacht auf dass hier von
menschenhändlern verschleppt oder gar
zur prostitution gezwungen worden sein
könnte auch hier ermittelte die polizei
wir hatten einen bereich in amsterdam
gedacht haben dort könnte er oder
rotiert er gewesen sein wir haben auch
dort hinweise versucht zu bekommen und
die niederländer haben auch eigene
ermittlungen angestellt letztlich
konnten wir uns aber auch nicht am ende
eine eine heiße spur bringen und wir
haben kein lebenszeichen vom tier ihnen
nie daran finden können auch ps familie
war in der holländischen metropole vor
ort um ihren geliebten sohn zu suchen
frank barke einem schlanken mann mit
schneeweißem h sind die an den nerven
zehren im jahre ins gesicht geschrieben
seine frau manuela pahlke lischka steht
ihm zur seite und schaut liebevoll zu
ihm hoch während er von der
verzweifelten suche nach pia berichtet
wir waren wir haben vor einem rotlicht
haben auch geburtsdaten und alle anderen
gefragt
alle spuren soweit sie auch führten
mündeten im nichts allen hinweisen wurde
nachgegangen doch der fall bleibt
ungeklärt und es bis heute eine der
rätselhaftesten cold cases deutschlands
was bleibt ist die ungewissheit frank
schneider kann nachvollziehen warum
diese sogar schlimmer sein kann als
einen geliebten menschen zu verlieren
ich habe mir die erfahrung gemacht wenn
jemand ermordet wird es dass das ganz
grauenhaftes uns schrecklich ist aber
die menschen haben irgendwann die chance
im jahr trauen zu beginnen weil sie
wissen dann was passiert es spätestens
im prozess zum teil auch manchmal die
details sind aber den familien haben
will an einem punkt wo sie mit ihrer
trauer und verarbeitung beginnen können
das ist in vermisstenfällen häufig
überhaupt nicht so weil man ja überhaupt
nichts weist und auch vielleicht die
sorge immer noch zu glauben seit lebt
mein kind noch wird seit jahren gefangen
gehalten und ich glaube das ist was viel
mehr zermürbt als vielleicht eine
grausame gewissheit bis heute haben
weder die familie noch die reporter oder
die ermittler in dem fall die hoffnung
verloren
bis zum nächsten mal sky dimo wache
pias vater hat an alle die diesen
podcast hören eine bitte
[Musik]
steckt bitte sagen sie wohl pia steckt
auch im kern ihm erleben sollte bitte
ihn brauchen der polizei ja nur ein
anonymer tipp geben das würde ja schon
reichen pierre page ist ein 1 meter 75
großer schlanker mann er hat blonde
haare und blaue augen er trug am
genannten tag einen cremefarbenen pulli
mit schwarzen streifen an den ärmeln und
aufdruck auf der linken vorderen seite
dazu ein dunkles t shirt mit gelben
aufdruck weiße turnschuhe mit
klettverschluss dabei hatte er außerdem
einen hellblauen rucksack mit breitem
riemen ist jemandem um den parkplatz des
penny supermarktes in essen frillendorf
etwas ungewöhnliches aufgefallen oder
hat jemand gesehen wie ein wehrloser
junger mann in ein auto eingestiegen ist
und weggefahren wurde
wer hat am 17 september
2013 oder in den tagen danach in oder
auf dem weg in die niederlande
speziellen amsterdam beobachtungen
gemacht die möglicherweise mit dem
verschwinden pierre parkes in
zusammenhang stehen könnten
ob täter mitwisser oder zeugen jeder
hinweis der zur aufklärung der tat führt
kann helfen die eltern und großeltern
von pierre zahlen für sachdienliche
hinweise eine zusätzliche belohnung in
höhe von 15.000 euro
wenn sie etwas wissen helfen sie den
cold case nach acht langen jahren
aufzuklären wenden sie sich bitte an die
polizei essen
tatort deutschland ist eine produktion
aus dem wakeboard studios
projektleitung simone terbrack
produktion fabian schaeffler drehbuch
nadja goldhammer redaktion bild frank
schneider und stefan metzen bank